président hollande a pris tout le monde
par surprise lors de sa conférence de
presse semestrielle ce matin à paris
avec angela merkel j'ai décidé de
prendre une nouvelle initiative
nous partirons à kiev dès cet après midi
françois hollande a dit qu'il avait de
nouvelles propositions précises à faire
pour amener une solution aux conflits
armés dans l'est de l'ukraine il
travaillait en secret avec son homologue
angela merkel depuis mardi mais comme
les précédents accords de cessez-le-feu
n'ont jamais été respectées par les
séparatistes russe cette annonce avait
donc aussi des allures de dernière
chance c'est l'option de la diplomatie
de la négociation
elle ne peut pas être prolongé
indéfiniment
le couple franco allemand a donc été
reçue en fin de journée par le président
petro porochenko à kiev pour une
rencontre de travail qui a duré
plusieurs heures pour l'instant
l'entourage du chef d'état français
parlent d'une rencontre constructive la
proposition sera présentée deux mètres
ou président russe vladimir poutine à
moscou pendant ce temps les états unis
ajoutent leur pression pour faire cesser
des combats dans l'est de l'ukraine pro
bac
d'état john kerry lui aussi en visite
officielle à kiev a réclamé de la russie
qu'elle retire immédiatement ses armes
lourdes des ondes cessez le feu et des
zones frontalières à washington le
sénateur john mccain demande maintenant
que le congrès s'engage à envoyer des
hommes à l'ukraine pour s'opposer à la
russie si le président obama refuse de
la faire les combats dans la région de
thoniers ont repris en intensité au
cours des derniers jours entre les
forces du craignait et les séparatistes
pro-russes des combats qui ont fait plus
de 5000 morts en particulier des civils
depuis le début du conflit en avril
dernier aujourd'hui l'ukraine est devenu
une source de forte tension militants et
politiques pour une grande partie de la
planète
les jardins radio-canada paris
alors on vient de le voir sur le terrain
les combats se poursuivent malgré un
premier cessez le feu qui avait été
négociée en septembre dernier comment
saint pierre bonsoir soit donc
l'objectif des séparatistes pro-russes
il demeure toujours le même c'est de
contrôler une partie dans de l'est de
l'ukraine c'est ça ils veulent un
territoire autonome une inte laval eux
ou encore mieux si pas de l'obtenir pays
à eux et pour ça si vous voulez votre
pays ou votre votantes lab autonome ça
vous prend l aéroport et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont battus vraiment ces derniers
mois ces dernières semaines pour
arracher donc l'aéroport de donetsk ils
l'ont lu si vous voulez aussi être
autonome ça vous prend un accès à la mer
un port la ville de marioupol en formant
encore là il ya des affrontements là ils
essaient sans les citoyens qui vivent là
ils sont pas nécessairement il a pu pas
nécessairement les pro-russes alors ça
va être difficile et si jamais marioupol
tombe ça donne un accès par la route
cadeaux accès par la route à la crim est
annexée par la russie de monsieur
poutine en mars dernier mais cette
annexion de facto de la cré mais ça
demeure un obstacle majeur là ce jeu
diplomatique auquel on essaie ça
monsieur alan le disait ce matin toute
entente devrait respecter l'intégrité du
territoire ukrainien on voit mal
monsieur poutine de se trouver là crimes
et d'autres viennent de s'emparer on
voit mal les pro-russes donc abandonné
les fameux territoire de qu'ils ont
arraché de dures luttes pendant ce temps
l'otan qui veut rassurer les pays de ses
pays membres qui sont autour des oiseaux
sur très inquiet alors les milices la
défense de l'otan ont décidé de créer
600 de commandement dans des six pays le
voisin auprès de la russie qui se
sentent menacés j'étais en pologne pas
si longtemps et on l'a sens le cette
crête dans la population c'est très
présent ce moment on va créer un centre
de commandement dans chacun de ces six
pays on va créer la fameuse force de
déploiement rapide trente mille hommes
dansent à une unité de fer de lance de
d'intervention encore plus rapide de
5000 hommes pour les rassurer encore une
fois monsieur obama lui fait l'objet de
pression en ce moment au congrès
américain de républicains et de
démocrates pour qu'on envoie des angles
plus lourde encore aux troupes
ukrainienne pour que puissent mieux se
défendre on parle ici de missiles lancés
l'anti tant qu on parle de blindés de
transport de troupes deux drones de
radars sophistiqués
monsieur obama pour l'instant hésite il
va décider d'ici peu il ya des pays
européens maintenant on a besoin j'ai
exactement mais il ya des pays européens
s'y oppose par exemple l'allemagne de
madame merkel parce qu est-ce qu on
redoute c'est que l'arrivée de ces
armes-là met le feu aux poudres et
déclenché un conflit plus vaste madame
merkel croit encore à la diplomatie et
sera d'ailleurs à washington et à ottawa
lundi pour rencontrer monsieur après
monsieur obama alors on suivra tout ça
merci beaucoup et mon équipe
nous